oh wow look I'm in space
[Music]
oh wow I am inside your mom this house
I'm such a genius I set up this green
screen right and I have not just
double-layer green shirts but also these
are my only pair over headphones yeah
good job man
Wow you're like super smart and stuff
it's gonna look crazy whatever okay
whatever we're playing evil with and
says can't even see anything cuz my mic
is like played I didn't think through
this setup whatever okay hey you
remember evil within it's made by
legendary horror game maker Shinji
Mikami which made the Resident Evil
series and considering how good the
Resident Evil 7 was I'm actually really
excited about this one see see if that
was kind of like catalyst for the future
of triple a horror games which have been
so god-awful for the past couple years I
have a sneeze coming
home engulfed in flames try to fire
kills child nanny I remember the first
game had the story of a like a spooky
scientist
it's a crazy scientist wow what an
original concept of the horror video
game I'm doing I'm doing I do look
forward to play this game I really do
because I hear it's actually pretty good
maybe a potential series you know
chef's the one begins it's not happening
I hate when that happens just come home
from a stroll in the woods and your
house is on fire but those pants those
pants
Moni oh [ __ ] the lilius family-friendly
still go ahead and say that Lilly is
done okay I think the game wants me to
go this way damn it how about that I did
it
[Music]
Lily I'm here where are you alright here
we go I'm gonna ship stairs Oh God let
me guess she's going to die and
therefore the horror character she just
serves as a purpose to make the
character have some sort of story how
did this
Lily what up dog it's your boy
I'm coming Lily coming come on me yeah
that's right he even said it
I can't sprint I'm here really nowhere
to go through here that's not gonna dude
I can crouch Shane
the game will teach me how to crouch now
how about that you have to know how to
crime [ __ ] in this game it's the
otherwise the spooky monsters Lily your
house is not even on fire yeah come on
out here you weren't here for me dad oh
my god she's already dead
punch her literally kick her she's a
devil
it's a trap it's a fake John
No
that's pretty cool I guess like the
classic storytelling of a guy having
guilt when it clearly nothing it was in
his fault to begin with but they always
have it oh I feel so guilty about this
one thing it really haunts me great
clearly we all saw that it wasn't your
fault that was all the times in movies
I'm so sick of that way of storytelling
why am I so critic Jesus Christ what has
happened to me it's been a long time
three years I've been trying to track
you down for three years and you thought
you'd find me at the bottom of an empty
bottle is that it and why are you here
now damn it you didn't find me because
they didn't want you to calm down
Sebastian you knew what was gonna happen
in that hospital didn't you what
happened at vegan is in the past you
need to forget it you sound just like
that psychologist that for still feels
guilty but he didn't have answers you do
you're gonna tell me about Mobius
Moebius oh my god did you guys hear
did you guys hear he said Mobius what
I'm here because of this
where did you get this it's the Lily's
still alive
hey now sit Sebastian calm down
lily is dead I read the police report I
was at her funeral we can rewrite
history if we want to help a child get
it child's play be careful in there
Sebastian we're counting on you
listen I'm just going to say my daughter
okay I don't do you think they'd let me
sober up first before they did this Sam
entry in three like why was I in a
wheelchair one
[Music]
okay
very cool very cool
no nose hair at all look at that
you must be [ __ ] that every day
okay I ride I control the camera for
some reason that with a
dos
cool I'm excited now can I play please
I'm the worst
I'm the worst let's player of all time
let's get real here you're watching the
wrong channel here here we go hey look
at that story in setting my where am I
people here we go that's the house
[Music]
I know it's hard to accept we're but
she's gone
our little girl is gone
no you won't help me I'll find out my
roots on my own hell is this place
detective well what got a call is that a
phone could that be her calling us from
the outside that might be pretty cool
huh oh man yeah hello it is her what he
made it safely how are you feeling yes
[ __ ] up Sebastian like the worst
hangover ever don't worry it will pass
once your mind has adjusted you're in an
area separate from the main system right
now that's how we're able to maintain
communication with you this construct is
called your room it's a safe zone that
was formed from your own memories my
memories huh that's cool if that's the
case and where my wife and child
this place looks it's gonna keep us at
crimson city
thank you it's a cure luge here you can
name hey ha I didn't see it does it
speak the cat speaks I bet you it speaks
slide projector
where did my mom hangs up elementary
school what up kid II can't what did you
want
don't don't no kitty get away from the
jar green gel it's gross and it usually
comes from dead enemies but if you
collect that you can use it to obtain
increased abilities Thank You kitty for
the green cow
anytime my man anytime my main guy save
[Music]
let's do a little let's do a little save
there huh I'm playing on the hardest
difficulty by the way there I'll
probably change it later okay there are
photos of a bunch of your team great so
your experts need rescuing - thanks for
the vote of confidence but I'm only here
- fine really
okay chat that was chapter 201
okay I don't know how I did that I
investigated that's how you open a door
everyone search mobile you search team
members within stem for a lead on Lily I
merely the freely as I really should be
a way out I couldn't my memory just make
regular doors came there mirror mirror
on the wall again into the looking glass
here we go again
into the looking this is how you do it
correct
it's okay
mom can fix it for you she can fix
anything
Sebastian
what's wrong are you alright why does my
wife look like a frame my god I picked
the wrong line amazingly smart and
beautiful life why wouldn't I be alright
come here
I'm looking too hard it's making you
delirious are you sure you're not coming
down with something
[Music]
and we're back inhale great wow what a
good thing that we didn't walk any
further is this the right place
well we don't really have many options I
want to get the gun one time oh cool
messed up isn't is running animation
really weird this is the belt
1:02 okay seon-ah
that's where we came from as a mirror
are you kidding me oh yeah mind [ __ ]
me right now one day you giving me a
little [ __ ] new leagues are locked
probably both of them not even gonna
bother very strange okay so if we go
through the door again got a flashlight
very nice
wonderful pictures very nice
oh that's not how you chair stupid chair
[Music]
what the hell
whoa hahaha that's I should have some
slow mana the search team Baker
I'm guessing I can't interact with it
that's cool man
yo Baker how you do men
is everything slow-mo for me as well
then
[Music]
the team leader maybe has something on
him one bullet straight ahead
wonderful Wow
how nice okay am I done here yep
strange people are very strange these
days you know that reference good on you
guess we'll check if there's something
here someone tried to block the way out
partying okay
potentially escape route for later
[Music]
sadistic we got a file everybody over
did this must have enjoyed it how is
this even possible well we're in a dream
world so I don't know why you would
question their how's it possible Beezus
bathtub
great
who's walking circles
I did this is another library no it's
the same what are we looking for I don't
even know someone locked the door what a
newpsie doopsy should remove this maybe
okay there you go a very nice I must be
a genius to get through that how about
that
okay I guess we're going this way just
about to say there was a phone before
I'm like I'm sure it's gonna ring hello
mina-san it's pretty pie this hello he
does good good prank old buddy
ha ha ha ha ha got you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
Sebastian where is my daughter
where is she I'm gonna steal the
Declaration of Independence I'm
Sebastian
[ __ ] I just do the Crouch cuz I'm so
best i collected another feiiow but
they're an extravagant letter alright
you can read that if you feel like
that's your thing can you do a quick
turn yes you can
camera is not as quick down
hi hey damn it what's going on here what
is happening here I am Sebastian and
there's like something really strange
going on in this place
it's really weird
oh my god is this game supposed to be a
horror game well that's cool it's very
visually cool but like it ain't scary
dog love the floor
very Twin Peaks
Wow he is a bad man oh he takes picture
when he kills people
I see but what's that okay so we have to
be covered hold to enter cover r1 okay
and then move alongside when near corner
icon will be displayed in that direction
okay so I think we have to move this way
right
while he's super scary can't seem to
move
who the hell was that
alright well I did it somehow anyway
even though I failed amazingly just like
the search team are you doing there
buddy yeah you're right everybody Oh
sexual I like that look at that very
very nice
oh my gosh ah you imagine that that's a
good way to die just constantly moaning
ah okay alright we're here now I gotta
find a way out of here but you just
joined stay a while I thought we were
looking for your whamon alright so we
checked upstairs we didn't really check
here hasn't because there's nothing
there Felix that's why I have this large
sound
spookie I can we jump down probably
should whoa whoa whoa was that a
mannequin head that's awesome how cool I
don't think you guys were hanging here
before very nice
should we go down here all right I think
we want to stay off that guy right I
can't go up so we gotta go there man
it's getting it's getting more and more
intense excuse me pardon me sir I'm
looking for my daughter I think you can
help no you can be great help it's this
place supposed to make people happy cuz
they ain't doing it for me man my god it
looks [ __ ] on PlayStation look at that
it looks awful what happened there look
at the tape there's no textures Christ
only when I get closer
it's pretty good art design I do like it
oh I thought maybe he would come out all
right okay
which floor 13 remember the elevator in
Silent Hill where it's missing one floor
and then you do the thing and then all
the sudden there's an extra floor and
you're like whoa what the heck man we're
entering a bad place now definitely no
that's the kind of feeling I miss from a
lot of horror games this seems like a
lot of a look it's blood that's scary
right look is that people let's that's
scary right hey you guys doing just
hanging around
oh that's a night maybe cooler one of
them grabs me or some [ __ ]
are they changing this is worse than the
Rick and Morty porno
I'm Audi oh that can't begin he's
playing with this what I didn't what a
crazy guy that's crazy man
what a crazy me I'm guessing this is
just like the intro I'm sure the game
will pick up its gaming elements instead
of having this walking simulator is
awesome are we gonna run oh we are oh my
god hahahaha
Brendan consumes stamina oh well I think
that's not really my biggest issue right
now that's cool at the cool-looking
monster right there shame I can't look
back because I kind of want to see how
she looks like but I feel like I
shouldn't I don't know how to jump ok
did it for me Oh excellent that's
perfect thank you
no this is just like the first game you
have to figure some way I had to escape
before timing run sound
[Music]
climb climb damage the crazy chainsaw
lady will get you aah
same kind of wanted to get killed by her
god damn it
she looks so cool ha ha I was awesome I
really enjoyed that hey look it's a red
oh my friend well I guess we're not
friends
Oh Mike you killed mr. Hecht you monster
how could you do this got an answer now
I know for sure that she's a bad person
but was willing to give the benefit of
the doubt for you now oh I don't hear it
well you made a big noise jumping down
I better be sneaky yeah all right I
can't run or do anything
oh my gosh she's so cool let's do sprint
consumer stamina so what big chase my
chainsaw guy oh [ __ ] oh no we didn't all
right that can't be good we're gonna die
we're almost at we're almost at game is
doing it for me that's cool
didn't want to play anyway all right
what the [ __ ] is going on here all right
what do you guys think I think it's
pretty interesting it seems to be very
similar to the first game but it runs a
lot better and it's very pretty
let me know if you want me to do more of
this I like will come a long way I would
really appreciate that it really helps
me out a lot and just let me know I
probably will play more of this anyway
to be honest with you because I do like
it so far
not like super impressed but you know
I'm hoping it will pick up that last
part was really cool oh my god that's it
for me for now brofist